it just made sense to us that the  grandest cinematic events in Marvel  history should be executed in full IMAX  level of ambition in these phones is  pretty high we needed equipment there  could to help us fulfill that ambition  as filmmakers it's an amazing tool for  us the way that it captures light the  way that captures color there are  fantastic cameras the chip is incredible  it's at a resolution that is  unprecedented the IMAX screen has a  different height than a traditional  movie screen having that extra  verticality gives us a wider range of  how we frame how we shoot these  characters  it's just presented on a much grander  scale of the nutritional indicator  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you